here with more former democratic
congresswoman from hawaii tulsi gabbard
um welcome back you know i looked at
your comments your fri you're friends
with both mansion and and senator cinema
you've had conversations as i understand
it with senator cinema what is she
saying
you know i've known kirsten cinema for
many years and she is not one to
sway to political pressure she does her
research
and she will she will stick to doing
what she believes is right you can agree
with it or disagree with it
but i think that those who know her know
that to be true the most important thing
as we look at what's happening now here
across the country sean is that we have
real leaders leading our country and to
me real leaders means those who are
putting the interests of the american
people ahead of any political interest
putting the interests of the country
ahead of their own partisan power or or
ambition and and that's what bothers me
so much about what we're seeing with the
democratic party now is that instead of
doing that instead of putting the
interests of the american people first
we see them pushing their own selfish
interests the interests of the powerful
elite and instead of truly serving the
american people even worse they are
treating us as though we're the enemy if
you disagree with the democratic party
you're called a racist if you disagree
you're called a russian asset
if you're a concerned parent who's who
wants to be involved in your child's
education you're targeted by the
department of justice as a domestic
terrorist unfortunately you could go on
and on with these different examples
that really just show how destructive uh
this leadership actually is
well let me assess the biden presidency
look for example
i can't believe we abandoned americans
still in afghanistan that shocks my soul
or my conscience i can't believe that
joe biden you know is allowing the
disaster at the border to happen that's
that's
he he's facilitating that i can't
believe he removed america from energy
independence i can't believe we have
more people dead from covet in 2021 than
2020 he was handed three vaccines and
monoclonal antibodies i can't believe
inflation is through the roof i can't
believe the supply chain mess i can't
believe china's aggression iran's
aggression north korea's aggression
putin's aggression uh is there anything
you can point to that you could say wow
that's really working because i can't
well i think you're pointing to so many
of the really serious challenges
that the american people face you
mentioned afghanistan that that one hits
close to home of course and and we have
to remember there are still americans
who are still stuck in afghanistan now
even though they may not be in the
headlines every day
and and this is where the american
people deserve that kind of real
leadership where they can trust hey
those in positions of power in our
government are actually going to look
out for us
but it's not surprising that as we sit
here
the american people wonder how can i
trust my government my government sees
me as the enemy uh without this faith
and trust that we have leaders who are
actually working to solve our problems
the the everyday serious problems you
listed many of them that the american
people are facing all across the country
then what are we left with
let me ask you a question i
i don't remember as distinctly
especially when you were running
in the primary
i don't remember you standing out this
much from the crowd
did i just miss it or have
have
that's a fair answer
because i i i've called it straight
shaun and i you've had you know i've had
a couple of conversations i've called it
straight whether it was with the
democratic party the republican party if
there are things that i agree with based
on substance not partisan politics but
substance i will say so and take action
based on what i believe is in the best
interest of the country and i think that
there's a direction that's wrong
i'll stand and watch out against it then
it's obviously a passion you have
what is do you have a planned future do
you have any thoughts about running in
the future
uh
there are many ways to serve
my sole focus whether it's in office or
out of office wherever wherever i go or
wherever i end up
my my commitment of my life is to serve
the american people and defend our
constitution and our freedom
uh well we share a common purpose
because that's what i believe in liberty
freedom capitalism our constitution and
there's the greatest country the
greatest wealth creating system on earth
and we have a lot of problems to fix
thank you tulsi gabriel thanks for being
with us hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else